are we on we on we're on we have special
co-host today Brian's playing grab-ass
in Utah
just kidding by grab-ass I mean he's at
his father's 80th birthday celebrate I
know Brian had to get tested three times
for Kovac before he went out there and
when he landed really good dad's 80 his
daddy and pop account
big big big cowboy own big big right
maybe like hug big Carl
Big Mike is big he's a big boy he's
worried about the covent yeah when
you're ready you gotta be big yeah yeah
and a celebrant
at a certain point you gotta just let it
let it go I'm counting down the days
yeah yeah I can stop biking my meeting
Yambol food I just wanna let myself go
80 is the time to do that I'm glad Kalyn
got tested I keep getting too you know
and I feel great I 104 temperature I
feel great okay so good I just feel good
I feel clear you know I just am sweating
and I feel better yeah I just feel okay
you know it's not a it's not a big deal
Jun did you see the video that Tim
posted of him as the coronavirus yeah
you guys yeah it was good it's so funny
you know can we play along here not get
in trouble I'm sure right um yeah I mean
you're allowed I will allow it
thank you I will allow it how great
would it be if I went back I called my P
my life I'm like yoke file file move
against them right now get a strike yeah
you can play if they just [ __ ] this over
you know my brother texted me that's I
felt my brother Tyson goes it's rare and
it's a hater yeah that's where I laugh
out loud he goes watch this well yeah
you know what's interesting is like I
did we didn't even know what the video
is gonna be and I just all I wanted to
say was the line at the end where I
wanted to say I wish I wish I was AIDS
and and so I just had that costume made
4,000 bucks because I was like whatever
so I'm out of work
it's a really good costume designer
who's done a lot of shift like Netflix
he's good he did the Epstein temple oh
they did a lot of those costumes so he
just made it and then I was just and me
and my producer were just [ __ ] around
we had no idea and I ad-lib all the [ __ ]
then he added sit together play this
through so in minute 42 so [ __ ]
depressed
let me put full screen so [ __ ]
I [ __ ] hate my life my dad thinks I'm
a piece of [ __ ]
I've never accomplished anything because
she's the [ __ ] CEO Microsoft and I'm
a dump
I want friends I want to be friends with
people where people freaking out you
know hard yeah they were pointing your
cousin it's ours
yeah my cousin SARS I'd love to meet
this old [ __ ] i dentist Bill Gates my
mother's are back you think your
family's [ __ ] up I wake up every day
there's another [ __ ] news story's not
true
hi Corona
I'm trying to help these people they're
[ __ ] stupid listen I live in Fox what
kind of [ __ ] up she did I live in
someone's ass Candace Owens does even
believe I'm real let me catch that big
let me catch that [ __ ] in the whole
foods
I'll go right up your nose will not be
able to transmit me to human yeah we're
gonna [ __ ] we're gonna give you to
every single person that's what my dad
wants to do what's it put a little bit
of me in an eagle and give it to 8
million people what do you think that
does to my sense of self I'm [ __ ]
real deal you don't even know how I'm
gonna affect you nobody knows I might
like your body I might not I'm going to
some of these bodies and like gets me
the fun is they're gonna ask me what the
[ __ ] I want to do with my life I want to
put something I'll have a lifestyle
brand baby nobody's maybe [ __ ]
tik-tok nobody wants to all be the
tic-tock with copa90 no one wants that
so just [ __ ] alone all the time I
wish I was AIDS and it's Owen so car
credit retweeted it and was like [ __ ]
hilarious she did good for her she could
take a joke yeah it was good for Candice
Owens both so funny yeah it was funny
was that you wrote did all that yourself
read live it I just you know my editor
just follows me around with a camera
hotel and I just say crazy [ __ ] and he's
really is I mean that's what we did with
Meghan McCain every video I've ever done
it's like I just sit down and I just
start ranting he puts the camera on me
and then he just chops it up really good
now I'll make a suggestion here and
there but he's really good at like oh
I'm like this is the sequence of it this
is
how it gonna work yeah in the hell you
guys shot that help for how many offers
real sight for a while an hour and a
half but you know it was we had an hour
of footage if you got down to a minute
30 like there's a lot of footage and
there's a lot of [ __ ] footage of just
me walking by things like is it funny to
walk by a certain thing beam Allen [ __ ]
yeah all of that stuff then we just make
we've got them down to a science that
where we make it very quickly is anyone
upset no everyone's over - everyone's
thought it was funny why say that one
yeah yesterday he was freaking out what
to Venice yeah he's like it's just this
is disgusting I paid $20 for parking I
got back in my car
he's like governor Newsom you guys
should do something about this and his
boardwalk was disgusting before the
pandemic yeah like it was a problem
before it was much worse there's more
the pandemic yeah there's bumps [ __ ]
every every way every day everyone
Thunder people nodding off - and heroin
like the other thing is like dude this
whole thing about people partying in the
Ozarks it's like why does everyone a rat
now everyone's a rat and everybody's
like an informant cuz they have nothing
to do yeah I hate that it's so straight
ox dude I'm not in osek like I'm not in
party Cove in Ozarks that's not I
wouldn't have been there probably before
I don't care yeah I don't care I let it
follow it and all the people that are
mad at them they're like oh they're
gonna die it's like will you hate those
people I think you don't care about
people in the Ozarks you look at Florida
like my aunt Donna called me sick Heath
rides day people are gonna die they're
so stupid I'm like will you hate him in
any way from New York I roll the dice
now let him have fun party Cove in the
Ozarks baby it's fun they want to get
together it's what they want to do man
yeah I would love if they like did a
camera close-up on a dude there and they
asked him a question like hey why are
you out and he had like a brilliant
scientific answer
yeah though were like something really
smart you know he's like listen if you
look at the mortality rate over a period
of time and you're like why
Korona your minds blown he's like yeah I
can have a good day you know is it
thanks so much he makes all the sense
yeah yeah you like this guy's [ __ ]
grade it's like yeah let's get out there
he's smart but that's the thing I think
people just gonna have to stop ratting
other people out it's weird to me is
like there's two sides like I I can't
talk to my dad my boy Todd filming I
mean him were texting back and forth
about Corona and I he was like call me
like not gonna call you dude cuz we're
gonna end up fighting and then I'm not
completely on ice for two weeks yeah
like it's very like what's easy like
side listen people gonna die it sucks
nobody likes it nobody's happy about it
we all live with a certain amount of
risks that we take every day every time
you get a car you get on four or five
that's a risk yes every time you walk
out of your house it's a risk there is
we're incapable of keeping an economy
shut down forever and ended the written
the the risks of doing that and to
people are much greater I think than the
virus yes oh yeah I've lost some friends
over my stance on Corona like Rob
McElhenney well you want you want hard
chronic truth you're like it's not real
no I think you know what you're like
[ __ ] yeah hardcore nurses you went out
of control you were attacking babe
leaking people's faces yeah Rob macula
he goes watch the fight campaign and
couldn't disagree more with you about
everything you said on Corona by an
idiot but still love you like that's how
it should be and that's fine yes I said
it was real I said it was too legit real
but then it's like you know you start
looking at it and going what's the plan
here what are we gonna do cause we never
gonna leave our homes and found she's
like dude shutting down was a terrible
idea
yeah I mean that guy said vapor trust
like short and weird look and I don't
trust them I don't trust em he's just -
you don't want a doctor to look like
that when Brian and I are go on the road
this week with I think we're the first
like you're going to me some people are
doing like you know like this capacity
or what are you doing 50 percent
confusing 50 think by the time we get
there they'll be almost at 75 to 100 and
when are you getting there like slowly
trickling more and more take you're at
the end of July no we're there Thursday
oh wow all the show sold out and then
they just keep adding the capacity yeah
Texas man they're gonna do it they're
gonna figure it I'm doing it they're
good holy pigs and him and his family
had a straight restaurant how's it go
dude you're living 20 40 what's it like
he's inside he's inside
waitress full you know just normal [ __ ]
Wow
Newport Beach opened up the really
Orange County I think opened up the
restaurant they this weekend Huntington
I may drive down there later today I'll
Drive down check it out I just want to
see what it's about
I always go yesterday it was packed you
were yeah I was there did you go in a
restaurant no I was walking around I had
already Abe I wanted to sit down just
for the sake of being in a restaurant
you drink
I should have was it packed it was hat
and no mask no mask where people can
play man full of people with masks I'd
like to sit outside I don't know if I'm
ready to go inside I want to sit outside
I'm a little nervous about who I talked
about groaning I'm a little I I don't
know I'm a little uncomfortable right
well I mean Texas they have the they
have the thing where they go the only
vaccine we need is Jesus that makes me
think they're not super scientific in
their approach I also believe as much as
I also don't want to that see in the
open I really don't want like a vaccine
if this is disappearing and less and
less people are getting it who said oh
yeah do I want to inject myself with
this virus I don't really want to do
that to be honest with you who did you
inject yourself with a SARS virus no I
never got enough ag-1 island I've never
got a flu shot in my life and I've never
gotten the flow you seemed healthy and I
mean well you know we'll see but I my
blood is fine like my doctor he tells me
he's like everything about you is fine
he's like I don't want to tell you that
because you're gonna keep doing whatever
you're doing 104 times you know it's
like please like your blood Sugar's fine
is your cholesterol is like it's all
fine
so sometimes Irish guys are just meant
to to just be dancers or their 90 Drive
just is would it have you sex if I was
black I would die at 40 that's like
different it's a sad thing it's
different the reality it's just like
that's Friday those are just those are
number guys those are I'm a number
person I'm a number guy I'm a number of
guy are you uh when you gonna start
going back up on the road I have so many
comics so short
yes everyone's just like dude report
ASAP what's like on the road man want to
hear from you and and I you know I've
always thought about like you I Drive to
Phoenix Arizona and do a spot do I just
put on like hey I'm gonna be it whatever
it is stand up live HazCom wherever and
just go hey I'm gonna be there tomorrow
night it's 75 people max - I just do a
one-nighter for fun
I gotta drive there not have to you know
make a fly and all that well what would
you should do the shows with Brian at
stand-up live June 11 through 13 I'll do
that you do it I'll do that really well
absolutely not if you want me to do what
I'll do it I'll opener yeah yeah
I mean I'm on Salt Lake City in August
5th through the 7th I don't see why I
wouldn't do those no I wouldn't yeah
yeah so you don't your first time being
on stage you're doing a fall out trying
to work out that's what I mean that's
why I was like maybe I'll Drive to fiy
I'm very close to just driving to
phoenix and saying hey i'm gonna be at
this club tomorrow night selling the 75
tickets and doing a show you just to get
back because the last time i did comedy
was late maybe March first in the
original room Jennifer March I didn't
March less time to comedy yeah it would
be March 2nd dirt around the room in
March yeah yeah early March so it's me
College I want to get back in the game
100% come with us in June June 13th do
that
yeah and that's such a easy you can also
do us the smaller shows too on your own
out there have you flown since no
Thursday's the first day I'm going to
fly interesting cuz I'm curious about
that about it some people say it's great
because there's no one there some people
say they're packed are sitting next to
someone they don't like it so it really
depends on on how you
I also heard certain airlines they won't
let you on the plane without a mask yeah
and then once you're in the air they're
like do whatever the [ __ ] you want
yeah dude here's one good thing about
planes the air in the cabin is
recirculated out every like four to six
seconds I thought it stayed in now are
you sure you can look that up but it's
it's it's actually safer to be in a
plane than to be in a room like this did
you see that model I forget who put it
out part of the Democrats where someone
sneezes and this shows all the particles
of the sneeze going through the
playing Yesi on all modern aircraft
passengers and crew Bri the mixture of
fresh and recirculated air using this
combination rather than fresh air only
makes it easier to regulate temperature
at how maintain a bit humidity yeah but
it eat I think they just don't scroll
down I can see it there go it says how
often is it circulating the plane
fifteen fifty times an hour so be about
right I think I'm right
see this is it I don't know if they
proved me right or wrong with let's look
at this one I think you're right because
it's because I've heard that from people
that are smaller do 15 divided by 60
I've heard that from people that are
smart they're like sitting in a plane
because the air keeps pumping you know
III thought it just stayed in there
sound those people I don't already plan
I'm like well 0.25 so 0.25 so every two
and a half minutes means they're
circulating yeah I mean that's much
better than a room right way better yeah
or an elevator and they're also singing
out does it live on surfaces the way
they thought so I think that flying is
actually not that big of a deal I think
that there's still the biggest problem
is public transportation like Subway's
says New York subways are a problem
nightmare but I also read it again this
is the part of the problem of this virus
they also said you have to be in contact
of some between 15 to 30 minutes to
contract the virus now so they have to
be I don't have it you have to be around
them for 30 well I don't know if that's
true but let's say that is true on a
train that's easy super easy super easy
to be on a train for somebody for 20 to
30 minutes super easy on an airplane any
travel situation that's not a car that's
pretty easy true you know but I'm unsure
if that's case cuz if I spit and I have
the virus and it lands on your face and
you breathe in is it really gonna take
20 minutes I don't know you know risk
I'm willing to take that we all have to
get back to normal we all have to take
the risks people are doing how are you
explaining this to your son does he ask
crazy too young no yes yeah he's he's
like Papa why can it why can't I see my
friends why can't I go to school I go
the sickness that's good and then you
talk to like a horror movie
it's a sickness a good we call it the
nothing's
nothing is eating our way of life one
day we will be warriors and fighting
will fight at 50% capacity he gets Rick
and Morty references oh yeah that's it
but uh yeah um to the sickness that's
why I can't see his friends and then
he'll go pop up his favorite place on
earth is Disneyland yes let's go to
Disney yes sickness Mickey sick oh ok
sick interesting it's about now make him
fearful for his childhood oh you better
yeah I go they get better Mickey will
get better he's sick right Mickey is a
Mick son Mickey has AIDS in the early
90s ok
I wonder if Disney world's gonna get
back to being dissed Disneyworld
supposed to open in June they say
because Universal Studios is open and
Disneyworld complex is gonna hold the
NBA playoffs and finals NFL happens
right NFL is 100 cent happening the only
up in the air thing there is if they're
gonna the attendance they know they're
gonna have fans they don't think to me
the full amount but they're gonna have
fans okay then I felt the the lifeline
to those teams that's like Illuminati
money those guys all rich white guys set
for Jacksonville if those guys can't get
their thing open
we're everyone shot but it's open but
it's got to be open day yeah they 18
through this whole thing that's what's
so great about the NFL they didn't even
hesitate they rise though the schedule
like four weeks ago yeah everyone's like
well you haven't change anything like
yeah we're playing dude well I got
worried that they would say they were
borrowing for a minute they were get by
they were barring anyone that had Cova
19 tested positive from the military so
I'm like wait a minute what are they
what do they know yeah you don't know
they just reversed that policy yeah so
they're letting people in so I feel
better about it the mortality rate I
think is much lower than we we know
doesn't mean it's not a tragedy it
doesn't mean people can't get really
sick hundred percent I think there's
good writing people done I think there's
train in New York is rough cuz it's
coming from Italy and the one that we
have is from China and ours is milder
interesting yeah I think New York still
[ __ ] up cuz como is it coming
kwan/wong homo out there was like hey
old people unless you're showing
symptoms even though you're you test
positive I'm gonna put you back in the
old folks home so those who are over
eight that was a big
it's at risk they go back there so all
the bodies built up this yeah because
you don't want to overload the Hoss you
know I was like a Janice big mistake
100% so you basically gas them right and
was I we don't we don't we leave the
hospitals open but I also think there
are people and it's that are younger
know that you know right there are
people that are younger that are getting
super sick in New York and you're like
and their skin sick here but they're
getting really sick in New York and
you're like I guess maybe it's viral
load like how much of the virus you get
like if you're on that subway with
somebody for an hour to immune system
you down deep trouble like Michael Yost
on about how he didn't sleep for like
two days
yeah flu and then drove and then he got
it what's scary about that is a lot of
us when we were living on the road you
know we do push ourselves like you are
flying a lot you are I was talking to
just take care of ticket 5,000 IU's of
vitamin D every day
oh nice and tenth is 104 yeah my temps
104 mister 104 that's your new nickname
mister mister wanna war I um Rhonda
Patrick was on Rogen saying that is it
Rhonda Patrick so hot yeah I was gonna
say Rhonda Rousey it's Rhonda Patrick
who's saying vitamin D might be one of
the reasons the Sun Hat really sick oh
no I thought they're saying why no they
think yes son kills it cuz if you look
at right like the selfies if you're
deficient in vitamin D which Michael
yahwah's and and a lot of minorities are
because the melanin in is also Asian to
stops the synthesis of vitamin D he's
checking all boxes 100% Asian and I'm
with you he deserves it fine I get where
you're going I'm right with you but
that's what I'm taking the vitamin D but
who know I mean who knows man it's one
of those things where you're just
rolling the dice but everything arrived
oh I don't know the dice are in our
favor though you're cheating in our
favor
I mean perhaps you never really know I
mean that's a thing but I'm giving
Houston I'm only spending time now
around wealthy millionaires I mean this
is the reality smart I'm only spending
well the millionaires because they are
not gonna get sick no and if they do
they'll figure it out and that's a lot
of people say that's superficial or
wrong of me but I don't believe so it's
for my health
it's for my house though I'm only
spending time right people that have
compounds of states is your did you talk
to your family back in New York
no they're done you know explain that to
them I said hi guys you're in a
disease-ridden hellscape I'm not it's
time to just shut this down and I hope
you know I don't think I'll ever see the
meek now I'm literally I don't know the
next time I'm gonna be in New York I
don't know if I'll ever see them again
even if there's a vaccine even if it's
five years from now known as coronavirus
I want to honor the work that's done by
the heroes and probably just a but nah
I'm it's just talked about calm on the
phone but like I don't know what I'm
gonna see him dead no dude they do a
zoom call for Easter I'm like no thanks
no it's just 20 people I'm like Oh word
it's just not it's like my grandmother
being like I'm gonna stop it they did a
zoom Mother's Day call it's like what
are we doing do about an out I'm out out
so what you been doing like it you would
do binge watch shows what he do you know
a podcast a lot so I'm doing the two
podcast a week and then we do I've
always done too and I was just one
always done - I mean I do one and then
one for the patreon that's a show and
that's that's grown dramatically and so
we're doing that twice a week we're
making the videos you know whatever we
see a funny video you know I'm writing
stuff I'm trying to stay focused I'm
taking like long walks try to like try
to prepare my head for like what do I
want to do creatively when this is up
let me ask you this I was talking with
rowing about this before you came in
here this the one thing the quarantine
has done is its main realized I work too
much man
we all do I'm on the road way too much
we all do a madness go on the road more
strategically yeah cuz I'm doing three
weekends in row so that's four days you
know so don thursday friday saturday
sunday ZUP I'd come back what's really
not a day and then I'm home Monday
Wednesday you know a Wednesday I'm doing
the store at night and Brogan too much
travels like that to every one of us
should start thinking about being more
strategic and agree yeah I mean that's
the whole thing so one thing I learned
from this yeah Scott I caught Justin my
agent CA who hopefully you go over - I
was talking to him and I was like dude I
just I can't do those three four
weekends every month now yeah I just
can't it's hard you got to figure out
ways to maximize when you're out there
on the road but yeah but I mean I just
walk around I just walk
Beverly Hill I live on the edge of
Beverly Hills I just walk around and
Moses mosey around like $30,000,000
States I just kind of like walk around
and you look like a robber I live in a
nice area no I don't look like a rock I
just look like a guy who's like lost and
everyone's like overdrive look like a
guy literally look like a guy who
inherited money yes and died there Trust
Open the next scheme yeah they're like
it's a clothing brand like yeah they're
like this scumbag inherited money from
his parents you know and he's just
walking around Beverly but I love I love
walking around and just trying to figure
out like what am i dec how am I gonna do
this all when we're back up and running
yeah there's some things that are gonna
suck like the traffic when it comes back
it's been so nice getting everyone and
it started back it's time to come back I
hit track though Dan's like what the
[ __ ] man yeah I thought you asked for
this dude talking all that [ __ ] you've
asked for this yeah it was the economy
open back up you asked traffic comes
back and then you guys like we're like
like I'm also thinking about like
eventually I want to buy a house when
where I live I'm never gonna be able to
afford anything when like Beverly Hills
or any of that so like I'm going out to
like the desert nice like I'm out in
like I'm driving around like Agoura
Hills it's nice out
it's nice nice smell Canyon all those
are we thinking I'm driving around there
and I'm like look at houses like two
million bucks and I'm like not now and
not soon but I'm like eventually that
will be a reality but in my neighborhood
I walk by houses like 20 million but I'm
like yeah that's little Hills ridiculous
ridiculous nice it's ridiculous
I saw the only one that really lives
over there I know but that's of yeah
they don't want to know yeah so most
successful comedians are pigs to that
that's all Whitney that I'm like yeah
we're monsters like these guys made
their money like kha'zix tan with oil
dude these guys like yeah wait a minute
in the ended bill conti and the woman
speak at the table woman see the dead
Beverly Hills thank you Everly is my
woman is in Backhouse right now when I
need one of wives I go back there I will
sire her amick child and then but she
knows is be it Calabasas they put the
women on the TV it's no no no no I like
old school there I kind of like a little
I like old schools nice but yeah dude I
could get really into like some weird
desert thing would you be let out a pool
room I could get real thrashing me too
did you leave California yes
yeah he's limiting non settlements not
soon but I would be very down for tax
I'm open to it
I love Texas I like Texas decided Dallas
I like Dallas a lot what about Austin I
like Austin
I like San Antonio I like them all yeah
I feel I go that's it I like I like
Texas allow him to live in Houston
I don't like Houston it's not like I go
there too fat it's uncomfortable and I'm
a big guy I'm fat guy but Houston is the
kind of fat where it's like it's all
good roll hi dizzy Lancer I get worried
it's people that look like they're gonna
explode yes it's Noren mask it's like
yeah well it's a problem it's a Brooke
Chrysler I was opening for him and we
sat down in a restaurant in Houston and
we're just looking around like well
we're great we should just start
rewarding ourselves
yeah but he's this big but yeah Austin's
great Dallas is great here's one thing I
like Cali to there I love California and
the one thing I love the ocean I love
the beat like that's great
the one thing about California though is
you got a beast of a state tax right and
Texas you don't exactly think of the
money with it yeah that's a Florida and
Texas if we all went down there you just
we had a whole squad done yeah you gotta
you got to get a bunch of people to do
it yeah who would be in I don't know
Julio's not going daliyah's not gonna go
rogon we'll go we'll go go Rodan go
Allen Oh golly go see like oh we'll go
see how we go yeah baby Joey Diaz we go
oh I don't I don't know I don't know
either what about the New York guys no
no they're not going it wouldn't they
won't even leave New York I know it
won't leave New York in a pea this is a
crazy time to talk Christy come down
yeah
I do it everyday releases yeah I tell me
what are you doing what are you doing
I'll tell you this New York people are
so crazy right now they're shaming
people who left during the pandemic I'm
like why are what they're like they're
guilting people that left to be safe
like you should have fought this thank
you I will remember who stayed you
didn't shut up shut the [ __ ] up
that's Sony I don't want to live get out
of that [ __ ] that weird masochistic
relationship you have with that city
where they it's just a rule remember who
stayed here and died oh well you will
remember who went on a ventilator it's
like great some people want to get out
they've kids they don't want to [ __ ]
being a rat tunnel of disease you have
you seen them eight look this I Love New
York but it's enough sent off I mean
I've suggested and I suggested this and
this is not a joke and it's not and I
don't want anyone to go but I've said
because the disease outbreak is so bad
and I Love New York leave the building
is there a way to gas the people I
believe the building's start the
architecture is so gorgeous but could we
gas the people in their homes this is my
question and I'm not not being shitty
about it I'm not being a dick about it I
just think something needs to be done
yeah uh-huh
yeah look how many people are moving
from California to Texas right now it's
insane a lot right Jax is like hey
Colorado is cool but they just live on a
[ __ ] and yeah that's where I'm from
Colorado much to my total people are
moving to Colorado - yeah I could never
move Denver and its height was got like
thirty thousand a month jumping in will
you miss the beach though with the ocean
I kind of liked the ocean you know I'm
not there done I mean I'll go and live
by the ocean but I'll go in like once a
week I'll just pop that on Hermosa Beach
go and I like the idea that I can do
that but that's what it is I like that
there's mountains
oh [ __ ] like you're you can get to
everything then there's the
entertainment business yeah but I'm not
unlike movies and TV so I can kind of
relocate any but you know what I'm I do
feel that that's that will change when
like I think that's already starting to
change like not me
we but like I think more opportunities
are gonna open up for people that are
big in this realm and then yeah man dude
if we all did a movie we would you not
many people would watch it it should be
under our umbrella it should be under
our control that we should have license
to NBC or yeah but why why not be or not
sell Netflix for real money never what
you could sure yeah I mean I the way I
think about it I'm like if we all made a
movie and then sold it to Netflix why
not 100% you know that way that's what I
think I'm like I'm like you know I'm
like why not cuz I get bullets I love
podcast we also want to do all the
shit's why make those videos it's like I
want to do other stuff I get a little
bored yeah you're great you'll have your
own show soon then on the network but
also if you think about our group of
guys if you are in network because
that's what be huge it's like trying to
unionize [ __ ] UFC fighters yeah well
like everyone's like but I'm called
Spotify the day after row get signed and
I said I would like 85 million dollars
and they they were weird about it but I
say listen to me and [ __ ] [ __ ] I
also called Joe and I said there we are
you Joe
I've been on the show about three times
I think I deserve a little money here
and I will have lawyers denied a cube
right there I said I'll have lawyers
because I think I was on his podcast
more than anybody less nine times yeah
and Brian goes appear at the very least
you could buy us houses in Texas yeah
yeah yeah the deal you saw yeah it's a
good place and we could use a boat Joe
the least you can do how many girls I've
seen a dime from the fight completely
delusional Psychopaths now think Spotify
is giving the money how great is that
how many mentally ill podcasters are
calling Spotify I'm calling their agent
been like hey you any money over there
like how about Spotify just like oh my
god we [ __ ] up dude or we didn't
emails and calls non-stop people
demanding millions at all I just wanted
85 Mel I said listen
that's a fair deal yes by the way
Spotify buy me for two mill 1 mill
they're worth five billion now yeah just
just they paid our boy Rogen when you
think about it care of the people who
you need to take care of
that's all would you go there where does
YouTube come for you YouTube is screwed
me up which is why if you are watching
this please subscribe
Tim Dylan show on YouTube only
we were getting hundred thousand-plus
views on a lot of our stuff then and on
the like algorithm whatever happened you
know my producer put a knife fight in a
title knife fight in Malibu and I guess
maybe they're censoring it because they
think it's an actual knife fight it's an
expression I use that a realtor said to
me which I thought was hilarious what
the real I'll talking about renting a
place in Malibu just just seeing what
how much it would cost and you know one
of these you like grizzled old like
Malibu Realtors gets on the phone she's
like listen she goes she's the first of
all she has no idea who I am she's like
listen to him let me tell you how it is
it's a real knife fight out here this
markets and she's like people are just
they're just swapping their egos their
graven properties left to right because
I don't care about coronavirus I don't
care what the government said it's a
real night fighting here and I'm
picturing a woman who was not it felt
like I felt like her husband's [ __ ]
her assistant she's just creating her
teeth she's driving around and like a
white pour so that's a knife fight
smoking a cigarette
yeah just totally knife fight just
breaking in a house like it's you know
what I mean it's just just closing deals
that's the only dealing yeah it's the
only thing in nice voice you just closed
the deal that's the only way she can
feel but like I just thought it's funny
so I don't know what they're doing but
it's like it's dropped off significantly
recently and I mean even if you look it
was like 99 a hundred hundred seventeen
now it's like I mean this just came out
a couple of days gone it's 50 but like
they do strip away more than 50 dude
they're they're screwing with us well
what happened I don't see a lower view
count a lot of times they take you out
of the algorithm so let's say you watch
the Joe Rogan podcast or like some of
these things that were a few hundred
fifty thousand three hundred I have no
idea what's going on a but what happens
is something you did in there may be
cussing or some ref yeah maybe Thank You
Allah algorithm and then you can get
back in you it's tough to you back you
but once they take you out it's not to
you bet
I know so I'm just trying I'm just
saying listen raw subscribers watch the
thing it is what it is like I don't know
what to top it but we also started this
a year ago like we're late to the game
on this like we started YouTube a year
ago we started a patreon a year ago on
the patreon is massive describe patreon
patronage is a page you pay for an extra
episode of week so you get an extra
episode of the podcast every single week
for free and where do you get it and at
patreon calm
where it's not YouTube No so patreon is
a is a subscription service that a lot
of podcasters put extra content on so if
you go to patreon.com/scishow you see
how it works if it's recommended to
people end of it then there's no
regulation or there's no you can say
whatever you want you're not censored
nobody cares you can put ads on it if
you want I don't but you don't have ads
and then so it's just five or twenty
dollars a month and it's bringing in you
know we've got fifty to eighty four it
brings in thirty thousand a month right
now just on the extra episode because
it's a great deal it's five dollars then
you get four extra episodes that are
uncensored and they're not in or out of
an algorithm now why don't but why don't
we all just move there and do that but a
lot of it well you guys are making more
money with that so I'm gonna get good
decent money with ads - but it's like
Pedro it's a great way and a lot of big
podcasts are on there it's a great way
to like not worry about an algorithm
well these these massive podcasts like
come town which is massive chapo Trap
House makes one hundred and thirty one
thousand dollars a month you know some
of these Red Scare these are these are
big big shows are they comedy shows yeah
yeah yeah the space but they're not
they're New York based a lot of them are
political there's a lot of political
shows on there too but they're huge
shows and they have that's so you know
plumb town's got thousands and thousands
of people so cool I'm dumb town tiger
bellies on there
yeah tiger belly through some stuff on
there interesting come ty doesn't see um
or see um tea o WN but of course it's
you and do look at how good they're
doing these are three friends of mine
that are hilarious are from New York
comics yeah dude
the cup boy sorry it's their shows go
come down and you know fifty-four
thousand a month and again it's all
funded by people that want to listen
like it's not you know it's not like ads
and then you're not worried about being
in and out of it now I'm not doing a
commercial for page now but like it's a
great way if you're putting out he's not
really money yeah scroll so premium
episodes access to all of our premium
episodes one week plus access to live
shows and possibly video content then
the Nazi pricing it was just hilarious
Nazi but ya nah fret C deals the firearm
out but
please pay this mat if you're one of the
Nazis in the podcast yeah so we can feel
okay about it yeah that we're doing all
right all right
$25 but seeing us fight on it but the
reminders donated to the Roy bail fund
in memory of Roy Bell who died of small
dick itís RP okay so it's like this is
what a lot of podcasters but on a month
if I goes back free five dollars a month
you get four episodes for me a month
that are ad free and if you give $20 a
month you get five 100 yeah it's not a
bad deal it's like the best deal you
know it's a reality dude but you know
it's good of ads I have ads my guys
great you know that's on the patreon I
know on my pop my podcast it really
funny if they $5 or whatever the [ __ ]
they pay more hours of ad Frechette it
should be at free I mean for the
Schneider but sometimes my ads are funny
like I people that get mad at me on the
picture exciton two ads tickle your ads
are funny
like my aunts are funny I'm sure that I
do you'll see fire D pissed if I panic
so cuz sometimes the companies get mad
but sometimes they like it like
sometimes they get it and I mean I sell
a lot of [ __ ] like we sell out of magic
spoon cereal I hear you but it's like I
also go crazy yeah and they're cool most
of are cool most of them are cool and
they get it but some kind of life
Matthew or man to the advertising Monday
calm no because at the end of the
article I still don't know what this is
like if you have a company from five to
a thousand people but don't know how to
send emails we will organize I'm like
yeah I'm sure there's a lot of thousand
person companies they can't figure out
how to get everyone in a meeting
dude watch we did a read into that or me
and Brian did a read for Toyota
yeah they launched a podcast that to do
we releases as a cartoon animation we're
doing this at and I'm like hold on
Toyota has a podcast going crazy it's on
their cars it's like haven't you always
just been clamoring for how the Camry
came about ah
do you know me and Brian we could not
get through the read we were laughing so
hard but we're not at least that I don't
think they ever paid us or came back
again but it was so [ __ ] I have it
too if you want you have it yeah you
know just a beginning you guys
please it doesn't have this chin of
course years ago years ago and this was
you advertising a podcast of Toyota
Toyota podcast yeah yeah yeah just sit
around like scrolling through some of
your podcast no you know what man
Toyota just isn't a car company they're
not you know Tommy I wonder what else
they are though you know you know what
they are their new podcast called Toyota
on tolls
[Laughter]
that's crazy
let's do this who gives a [ __ ] if we
fight somebody damn bro yo man yeah it's
hard it's hard it's hard to give who's
let's say you guys do it sometimes a
podcast yeah what were they thinking and
which one of our listening like Oh a
podcast on the history of Toyota yeah
scientists uh let's do it I want to know
how the Corolla happened yeah it's sad
but a lot of the companies are cool with
with the crazy ads I do and it's like
funny
pull up Tim Dylan dark wicks at what
they don't realize is a minute that is
fun allowing us to be as free and
creative as we want is what's gonna sell
their product if it gets really funny
like me and Theo did one on
postmates yeah and we thought they're
gonna be mad they're like dude we've
never seen such this old things like I
do ads like this but this show that's
actually worked this guy's number
yeah yeah yes it's actually this was
like everybody we have talked at length
about the importance of having a website
it is something that I think is
essential for people no matter how
worthless you are no matter how
worthless your product is how much
talent you lack it's a great place to
put all of it
it doesn't matter if you're good or bad
this societies no longer run according
to that little nas acts this is all non
tik-tok is like this goofy song and now
he's a millionaire and he's gay things
why so just imagine like you're in wigs
and you're like okay who's doing this
new ad and it's a five-minute date but
it's just a funny like it's just like
yeah you be like wig so you looking for
a way yeah I also put him in the middle
of the show so it's like I make them
flow with the show so yeah it has to
flow with the show and be on the lake so
I'm not making you laugh or I'm not
having fun why am i doing you know yeah
I don't have yeah you gotta have some
fun dude I don't know if do we ever
release the do we release that Toyota
pot yeah or the we actually did it for
them and then the accidents come back
one more time oh yeah they don't care
that's the other thing about them were
just like what have some do though yeah
interesting some dude what was going on
with the call your daddy people can we
talk about that oh yeah I saw them on
this I saw when I walked in yeah we were
talking about dude that's a good show
that's as big as Rogen it's so funny
like that's just America it's not as
Rogen's God has not like I know it's not
as big as ruggah but it's like mentioned
in the same sentence it's like Rogen is
like brilliant scientists and everyone
else and then it's like has nothing on
yeah it's like that's true but he's got
a lot of smart [ __ ] but this like what's
number two it's like call your daddy
it's like whoa there also an algorithm
with iTunes yes such a complete [ __ ]
show but nowhere near but there it's
probably more popular than it should be
I haven't we've had them on here yeah
we've come on here what do they talk
about the blonde girl is wicked smart is
it the light is it about calling their
actual fathers
no that would be awesome yeah I should
definitely do that it's basically like
the relationship with like dudes and
stuff right I think it's like them and
like girls and psych [ __ ] dudes and
like succulent sometimes you gotta suck
a dick yeah
answers for women yes two attractive
girls that again that blonde is legit
smart they were getting squeezed they
were against squeeze man this from I
understand you guys film it I don't know
the details of story I know from what I
know I know
that they kind of weren't anything and
then show it within barstool was like a
come on our platform we'll send all the
bros your way we're gonna give give you
an audience and this is the deal and I
know a lot of people my boys busting
what the boys is over there I know how
their contracts work I've seen them
KFC's there I'm real I like those real
bar school so I [ __ ] with bar stool so
they go we have this huge platform
here's the contracts like multi-year
three or four year cuddle the actual
contract was one year $75,000 each and
then at the end of the year they can
renegotiate no big was gonna be no bar
so Marshall took a chance on them gave
them a platform after year they signed a
multi-year deal right and then I think
it's the Burnet starts doing this like
HBO head of a sphere head of HBO Laura
gasp Laporte whatever and that guy goes
how much you make in your shows as big
as Rogen you should making this in this
let's get you out of the deal right so
then they called the guy who put the
deal together who humps friends with him
represents me who's their agent and he
goes let's get him out of the deal and
he's like well we just signed its
three-year deal so they have to once the
three years is over we have so much
leverage where these writers at 75 each
of now know is more than it was starting
at 75 with bonuses every single year and
then the second year is I think 85 third
year should have been a hundred grand
but you can negotiate at the end
well Franken between 250 to 300 thousand
I mean the reality is after a year they
probably should not sign that deal right
but they did and that's not in the marsh
- it is what it is yeah my thing we like
we're where were you before barstool
came about where where was your platform
no I'm sure because you've gotten to
where you're at without the push of
bartology big probably not because they
have such a loyal big following right of
Bros who are into this stuff so they do
that contract and then she started
staying home boy who doesn't know how
the podcast space works he's like you
should be making more let's get you out
the contracting the right has committed
this three multi-year deal they go the
agent put it together he's like no you
can't evolve you violate the contract
that we signed it's not smart to do this
then he goes we'll figure out hangs up
on my guy they fire my guy that you
don't know what you're doing fire him
knows what he's doing and then they're
in trouble now then word gets out the
trying WME and these other agencies to
get out of the contract so that's when I
did a split up I heard they must have
broke up and then they're also then then
her with homeboy and then the smart
girls a blonde who's I hate to be sure
but she's the brains of the operation if
the blonde leaves that show doesn't
exist well now at least umbrella it
shows John nope now the blondes do it I
think are they doing audition as
something to replace it they had the
president of bar still went on to the
call her daddy Instagram account and
said that send your audition tapes to
barstool podcasting works I will be
sending a tape you should do it would
have you had heard be great another I
was Santa tame but this is no different
than like like when a quarterback the
NFL signs a big deal or no you know it
is it's like those [ __ ] those kids on
Lord of the Rings yeah we know is gonna
be pretty big you signed this little
rings that the huge the books were huge
and then the first one comes out and
success i'm going i will restructure
those rings and the whoever put deals
like no dude we knew this was gonna be
big that's why we signed your multi-year
deal you gotta be care but worse yeah
you gotta be careful what you sign and
listen i mean they probably could have
made a lot more money if they didn't
sign ii like i understand taking the
knee if you're really huge after a year
you got a look at what you're signing
yeah i mean i mean it is what it means
for a reason yeah I agree
barbar
still didn't get where they're at off
I've no there's not no none of those
today I'm a they did what they should do
as a business
they gotta be sooo hard well following
that also catapulted these girls to
where they're at and those girls go
we're huge now we can do it without you
and bar seals like yeah we don't know we
have a contract like yeah but we're
gonna go over here well no you have a
contract right no no [ __ ] this yeah I
understand 100% kill him kill the
president Barse will actually
renegotiated their deal as well and he
agreed to do I believe it was 500,000
after each year no after the three-year
contract is over they would then receive
their IP back and then they would get a
higher percentage in March to so he was
really trying to make it work but but
yeah that's the again my boy will
Compton but some of the boys who I'm
close friends with he signed with it my
reviewed the contract it's not a bad
deal like if they sign a three-year deal
you keep everything after it's done you
you own the show you own IP there you're
leasing their rights
you're basically leasing your rights to
barstool in their platform to build you
up and after three years if you don't
like the deal you can go on you own it
all sure you're not saying we on collar
daddy we own busting with the boys no no
we're using our platform we like what
you do we want to add you to our network
after the three years if you don't like
what we do you're free to leave the hose
just want to leave early yeah no they
should not go play for another team when
you sign the [ __ ] three-year deal we
don't sign it through your deal if
you're if you're this is the problem you
don't sign a three-year deal if you are
you know if you want to be independent
I love independence right so my whole
thing is like I would stay independent
unless somebody gave me a lot of money
that's reality so it's gonna be a lot of
money for you to not be independent now
the difference is bar still built the
Bob correct yeah now it's a whole thing
have you heard of them before bar stool
with a you know I don't know them now
really did four episodes prior to bar
stool picking a bar stool saw potential
put money and their and the resources
into them they got the high level yeah
which I'm proud of me again that blondes
so smart man
and there's awesome there is a time to
leave I mean I was a guest a July like
yes a job there's also time to do water
I was with cast digital when I started
Lee just cancel those guys I'm told
friends with them but like there's a
time when you want to be independent you
go
have a boss anymore I want to you know
they're not on this coast at all gasps
digital but it's like I you know this I
get what they're saying to I don't get
running the contract but I get the
frustration of like I
they shouldn't sign a contract my money
should have sign the contract the
three-year contract yes really I don't
think there's [ __ ] without bar stool and
bar stools Wow the only way for them to
know is only one way to there's only one
way to now and then don't sign the
contract and find out correct and then
I'll come back to Barstow with your lady
you don't think they would have fans
without maybe not in the beginning but
now not to the level not without getting
in the vision of the present okay yeah
but then you're right but then it's also
like how much do you owe that person
they're willing to play $500,000 each so
a million so seven-figure contract each
Plus merch bar still sells a shitload of
merch I don't know what the merch deal
is yeah you're right maybe the merch is
good hey who knows a lot of money merch
what you can't do is go right we sign
the deal and then renege on that deal
and think you're bigger than the brain
you can't do that I agree with you that
respect is your best thing is is that
what because now they both hate each
other so the show's going why did they
hate each other
I don't know the blonde girl went and
she Rini renegotiated her deal because
they have separate contracts technically
they kind of made an agreement that they
would only renegotiate together as a
pair but when the brunette girl Sophia
didn't want to take the deal and wanted
to stick by her boyfriend the blonde one
was like I need to save myself went and
talked to the president and bar stool
and worked out her own could correct me
if tell me if I'm wrong the blonde one
also edits the show
yes edited the show she did a lot of the
marketing for it I love other news is
like 30 million unemployed also called I
mean it's a very interesting time you
know on edge of great depression also
call her daddy but this out is with it
with anything it's like well so real
quick the blonde girl she was actually
getting paid a little bit a little bit
more maybe quite a bit more because she
was also doing the editing but she
didn't reveal that to the to the they
didn't bring that check yeah so she
don't want that drama but she was doing
that chick didn't realize that she's hot
yeah staying three hours after to edit
this [ __ ] brunette chick was like you
know Ryan came to me and was like dude
why are you getting paid more
the brunette chick got lucky yeah she
fell into this that chick got rocky and
she just tried her luck and she lost I
like both them I'm talking with the
brunette she got with a HBO guy who
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's doing
right nice cause this turmoil and this
brunette chick I'd be willing to bet in
six months we don't know her I don't
know her name now no I don't know yeah
[ __ ] this girl yeah she had a great
thing here this could turn in a TV show
HBO Showtime getting out shows left and
right who knows they'd have been bad
could have been big there's no girls out
here like this you watch like what what
do they do
I'm confused there's a one and only what
do they do we don't love he's like
there's no one like this what do they do
again we don't know two black girls on
HBO had their own show and they start
from a pontoon job Queens you don't quit
yeah great name dope Queen tell Queens
to dope Queens and these I don't know
what they do but I feel like they're
like no no II things but they're two
white girls they're just they're queens
in their dog show
that's all you need now so I don't know
how that ends hopefully they that
blondes you gotta find that blond girls
gonna be funny Lorne s [ __ ] yeah he'll
be a pregnant HBO dude yeah poke holes
in those condoms yeah girl as a reward
for losing your career I know man wild
if that guy breaks up with her then
she's completely they should get back
together the two girls should get back
together and talk about it and me you
know because now they're probably gonna
have the biggest audience they've ever
had that's a smart move
I think that should go I [ __ ] up I
talked to the boyfriend like deflecting
silica gold Burnett like hey let's honor
our contract with barstool let's write
out the three years take from there
let's do this and they shall openly how
we fight you should let a lot of the bar
so guys do you like a [ __ ] on man
I just a way to like show that they were
wrong like to just let all the people
bar so just kind of jerk off on them as
a as it's about female empowerment
really because they're choosing yet
right it's not if it's your choice
they're the shoes out there saying hey
we were a little we were little wacky
let's lay on the floor and that
everybody jizz on us and then we'll go
back to podcasting it's just my thoughts
these are my thoughts that's if they if
anybody wants to hire me as a consult
that's cool too
Dave Portnoy hypes barstool sports
auditions amid call her daddy drama oh
I'm doing an audition man I'm going I'm
sure I'm gonna do an audition I'm gonna
put a wig on I'm gonna do an addition
I'd be like I'm this I'm the [ __ ] call
her daddy
stop bad yeah how big with that car yeah
I imagine that's a show I don't know I
imagine that's a good portion of it so
since Cooper made five or six thousand
frankly received four and sixty one
thousand we can't either this video no
in a 30-minute video but the first said
the infighting started as they began
renegotiating the second year the
three-year contract during the first
year it to be fair five hundred hundred
six thousand five hundred six thousand
New York's like making thirty thousand
in LA it's not a lot of money
it ain't a lot of money but it was money
goes further than New York not much
further
not much further not much why eight no
Texas you're Bill Gates but in New York
it's like bananas how much money you
have to have to have any space but
you're you know but that's what you
signed up for that's what you signed up
for it so I love the city a minutes yeah
I don't want to live there but yeah I'm
done with it too I mean I live there for
years and loved it but now I'm like yeah
I could never live there again no and
the reason is because of the call her
daddy drums I would have lived there if
the more daddy girls were treated better
knowing that they're not together it
makes me want to kill myself
like I don't this is nine twelve we had
nine eleven now we have 9.12 young sure
the veg 9zp before your podcast
producers have this crazy power of just
like you don't know where the footage
guy brian says it all the time right now
is a good thing chins on our side man
the [ __ ] we say yeah music what about
cat like I'm actually putting together a
tell-all book right now so Ayesha curry
is Steph Curry's wife and she recently
posted up a photo of herself in a bikini
normal whatever but a lot of people are
[ __ ] on her because back in 2015 she
released a tweet basically saying that
she doesn't like it when women come out
and like show their goods on social
media and there's no one's in - barely
wearing clothes these days huh
not my style I like to keep the good
stuff coat up for the one who matters
well I think she might mean like she's
also a very thick back in everyday life
and now she's just wearing a bathing
suit you should also got her [ __ ]
together she's in shape and she's like
that's what a lot of people are saying
they're saying that she's projecting the
fact that she probably didn't feel very
good about her body back in the day yes
and that's why she tweeted that and no
differently these plus-sized models who
shame the hot girls or you know the fat
people shame the hot people yeah it's
like that's not beauty you're empty
inside all right if you look like that
you'd be posting a speaks left I think
it would be a funnier post if she was
400 pounds right up humor I'm like you
know did she did she respond to it or no
no she did not that do you girl [ __ ] you
I'll show you the internet craze 2015
was a cake remember he said this in 2015
yeah well and then people are also
bringing up I think it was in an
interview a couple years back where she
said Steph her husband is consistently
getting attention from women but she
gets no attention from men on social
media hold on what about waiters she was
fat men care yeah yeah I remember that
she's like it's a little it gives me a
little bit of insecurity because my my
husband eats all this attention yeah oh
you mean the MVP of the NBA's getting
attention and you're not are you out
your goddamn life why don't you go sign
up why don't you do something to get
attention this'll do it though and
that's why people are she looks good she
looks really good yeah it looks better
like you better when she was lost faker
she's good she's still got it she's got
a long way to go this is I don't want to
lie to her I don't wanna well I'd like
to see him woody what I mean let's just
start focusing on trimming the hips a
little bit trim it down a little bit you
know well it's still too thick for your
liking it's a little thick I like a
woman who's 80 pounds bird-like ostrich
stuff you get very nervous remember
Calista Flockhart from Ally McBeal her
waist she was like a CD like a compact
disc
that's what I think Hollywood needs I
just what kind of [ __ ] losers Hilary
2015 yeah Hilary Duff's better at her
holiday weekend denying garbage child
child comment too funny but she did post
a creepy picture of her kid really well
well it's coming from that photo right
there's like a weird and that's where
everyone's conspiracy go yeah a photo of
one of her sons and it basically was him
half basically naked but you can kind of
see his butt and he had lotion on him it
was on her Instagram story she took it
down because people said that she was
not running a human trafficking thing
but it's like don't do that yeah just
don't put a naked picture of your kid
who has no say and you know what I mean
but I also don't think she's human
trafficking no of course she's not
absolutely not she doesn't have any
[ __ ] money that's the people these
thing with these Hollywood people they
think everyone Hollywood's got money his
pitch can't traffic traffic in the south
listen yes
she's got no but can we all stop every
everything's not the same here
trafficking pit I was like Jeffrey
Epstein they they were [ __ ] they had
real money that people that real
connection yeah it costs a lot of money
of traffic you yeah this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know come on stop do also don't put
a weird picture of your kid on the
internet like that just we've got it all
taken down yeah she took it down to her
I used to work out next to her she still
work out same gym yeah smoke show yeah
biess - she used to work out like I'm
not strong so she so this a little
picture of the little boy and his pants
are down uh Hugh is it seemed like it
was a picture of him after like he had
taken a bath or
something you could see his button and
there was lotion on him okay and it was
just kind of like supposed to be a
family-friendly photo of her son he's
laughs she's trapped in the trial yeah
well yeah it's a pill you gotta stay off
the comments you know all right
I always would want to say pictures I
like Hilary Duff I don't care either way
it is with trafficking human she's not
stretched she's not trafficking any
traffic career yeah that's what I mean
about people think Hollywood like all
these big power players and it's like
nod
I know people who live in cars I mean
she doesn't but it's coming
turn it around living in a car this yeah
that one okay that's weird it's not
great it's I listen I'm not saying
listen I'm not saying she's trafficking
but don't put that on social media yeah
you know what I mean
agree do not put that on social media
that is a bad kid I would never that is
[ __ ] not what you do I don't know
what it's all but that's also on her
refrigerator and she's just showing the
whole thing try to even think about it
because she's not trafficking human B
she didn't put that on Instagram reports
kept saying she put it on it okay a
story it certainly going over a fridge
of all the memories and there's a
picture of the so I thought you put it
in motion
because you put lotions on kids before
they go to bed because they have real
sensitive skin I do it with my son I
have people come and do it to me as well
but ya know that's uh you know listen
man everybody's not traveling it yeah I
mean this is like mental illness will
just stop I mean nobody's but the
pilloried are all the result they're all
right here's the thing there are
powerful rich people that do engage in
crazy behavior and they really never get
in trouble for it
Hillary Clinton's will knows I mean I'm
not playing your Hillary scam if you got
your Hillary's mixed up that's what
happened yeah that's exact coordinates
Hillary Hillary that's what it is
because no one gets in trouble and
there's no consequences people just run
right and they get upset and they're
rightfully obsessed and they just run
rampant and then they're like yeah
Hilary Duff's running a human
trafficking ring and it's like Dutch
probably not guys she's probably not
well you got you guys were mentioning
this earlier that looks so fun it's fun
man it shows arcs I would build in like
everybody's face yeah I mean I wouldn't
I know
consonant I chose it even if I get it
I'll be fine
look at the odds but yeah this is the
pool party from this past weekend I'm
all about it I'm here for it yeah start
living your life everyone's [ __ ] on
the party like everyone on Twitter it's
like oh that sort of looks like a house
shut up
what do you think your party's fun in
Echo Park where you sit there and you
talk about all the sins America's
committed shut the [ __ ] up I just can't
have fun there's booze yeah we're gonna
water and the water you're pissing in
the water who cares everyone's [ __ ]
in the water nothing better I just can't
believe somebody to post this much can
you believe these people
that's nothing to do with you it's
nothing to do you go right and father's
directly affecting you you don't want to
go to the beach and stay off the [ __ ]
beach yeah who cares don't be a rat
don't be a rat I hate that dude
I hate her quickly people became rats
like two weeks in people like are those
16 year old skateboarding it's like stay
out of it to cost you six and I made it
cool to be around
that's it think of it Hilary Duff don't
be a rat let her run a human trafficking
ring stop being a rat all denied right
she's got to make money she's getting
older as a woman in Hollywood what you
gotta do
you're right that looks so fun I can't
wait for those days I'm gonna back in my
days I mean right now alright there's a
quick sad one I don't know if you guys
know this person but I watch this show
called terrace house on Netflix let's go
on terrace house never heard of it okay
it's really good
you you wouldn't know it it's a
psychotic what's it about it's different
people moving into this little house
it's almost like real world but they're
there to find a relationship
it's a Japanese until it's all it's all
Japanese people I love how you guys even
thought there was a possibility like we
don't know if you guys work terrace
house the old Japanese dating show on
Netflix like you know we don't sorry
it's like you love the site but all
Japanese be on and you gotta read in
subtitles you guys speak Mandarin right
he's looking show you see that Schumer's
the host I think you guys you guys just
give him what it's one episode yeah one
episode of try alright
why what happened so this is uh one of
the girls that start in it she was a
professional wrestler I guess she has
lineage to when I think her father's
were also a professional wrestler and
she would get negative comments you know
like people say negative things on
social media whatnot that's social media
in 2020 what it is it's people got in
some ways it's worse in Asia like in
Korea remember like big celebrities in
Korea they end up killing themselves you
know it's bad here it's definitely bad
here yeah sometimes I do it depends what
I say
would you get more faith like I go I go
like sometimes if I go at Trump I get it
and then if I defend Trump I get it and
I do both right cuz I get a book thank
you all the time so like yeah it depends
yeah if you how do you deal it's like if
it comes with Fame I'd ignore it I don't
worry comments who cares you just ignore
it you know yeah I look at the Tiggy
Kali oh is this look at the rice people
watching people write tickets people buy
them right
I don't give a [ __ ] who cares yeah
something I take it harder than others
but yeah it's the way they do it it
she's very like I feel like everyone in
Asia is like like we write people off
here but if somebody says I'm an Asian
you're like yeah yeah yeah
so she was reading the collection look
she sana so she sorry you have to so not
your whole country by your appearance on
dating show you like [ __ ] sorry
so she was a victim of cyber bullying
she mentioned it before and then in her
last post she had like a little her
little cat and she was saying something
like you know goodbye or something like
that they usually love how much agents
love cats because I think cats are
awesome
and certain Asian countries a cat is a
status symbol that's not directly
related to this but Ronda Rousey posted
this I feel very bad for this woman I
feel bad that she committed Ronda posted
about her yeah a lot of wrestlers in
it's very sad you can't listen to people
online are monsters you can't listen to
them I don't know what to tell ya yeah
you know
Ronda put cyber bullying is a very real
and growing threat to us all in society
succumbing to isn't weakness it's human
we've evolved to feel as if our lives
depend on social
acceptance because the majority of human
history of our survive has depended on
our social groups and standing within
them I know the trolls that spend their
days harassing others online are bound
their own mental demons true but please
find a way to release your venom in a
way that won't poison others even a
straws weight can be the one to break
the camel's back is what Ryder she's
really God no idea that came from Rio no
Ron - wait get smarts that's [ __ ]
good smart I don't know if she has her
high school done that was Rhonda we'll
get smart yeah run is very very smart
this is Nikki Bella words can destroy in
a minute what a heart had to build in a
year but also stay off social media yet
listen this is easier said than done
Bono snapped when you're in the public
eye Canty degree is that people gonna be
shitty to you you have to take it you
know what take it but like I know Chitti
but it's so shitty but also if you have
an opinion if your opinion a person
that's yet you're gonna upset I'm just
gonna have to people and have to be
we're gonna [ __ ] with you I absolutely
you gotta accept that half the people
aren't gonna agree with you and half
those morons are unhappy with their
lives and the only way they can do that
my promo people might hate you
celebrities might hate you it is what it
is you know I went to Hilary Duff's
house to make a citizen's arrest she's
not happy everybody's gonna have a
problem with you imagine that I show up
at Hilary Duff's house yeah she that
[ __ ] doesn't live in Beverly Hills
Hollywood Hills disgusting little hots
buried in the side of a [ __ ] Hill
with a 4-foot infinity pool and kind of
[ __ ] my horseman I don't know what
money is oh forget it
Mick Foley would big bully put also
known as what's big Foley's behind right
dude yeah Hannah Kumar was twenty two
please let that sink in twenty-two yeah
online bullying should not be part of
her life it damn sure should be not
should not be part of death well what's
good is that we have a pro like the
president doesn't really participate in
this negative he doesn't roll people at
all what's good about the presidency
sets a good example [ __ ] it's bad it's
bad it's it's bad when people put so
much weight in the social media that's
what's bad thank you yeah it's not real
it's real it's real
looks good it's not real and of Israel
dude none of it's real it's not real you
just have to [ __ ] ignore it but it's
hard to ignore you like Lance Armstrong
it's very hard to ignore the only way to
defeat like trolls is to ignore them but
it's the hardest thing in the world to
do it's very light Trump but yeah you
because no one can ignore him you can't
ignore kid president but also the way
you beat them is just more success yeah
that's what you got to do yes
okay well just to close this off there
what she said last was I love you have a
long happy life I'm sorry and then
tragic that was her with her cat how did
she do it they're still investigating
exactly what happened there was like
zero is is there any possibility that
cat killed her and then wrote that post
oh my god that's what I was thinking I
mean this literally time cats are
devious is fats are very mischief cat
sack will make it look like a suicide
well it's a kid there's a great meme or
think it was like a phase of a cat and
because I cannot spread coronavirus
though if I could I would thought of
hilarious cats are [ __ ] [ __ ] I hate
you have a cat right well that's not my
friends my friend's cat that big fat
grey cat hey it's just hilarious I put
it in all like we put in all them is so
allergic it's just so funny it's
hilarious his name's Oscar just hates
everything it just makes me laugh like
I'll pick it up it like it's the clawing
of my neck and he's trying to kill me
friend it is this big glob no no it'll
get ya what's this this is a comparison
people made to President Trump and then
also Michael Scott from the office so
it's about positive and negative I'll
just play the clip for you here a
two-week regimen of hydroxychloroquine
and I've taken it I think just about two
weeks I think it's another day so and
I'm still here I'm still here and I
tested very positively in a in another
sense so this morning yeah I tested
positively toward negative so it's so
confusing perfectly this morning meaning
meaning I tested negative that sounds
like me as a president alright then that
can help my words up all the time
no I have not and then if you remember
watching a the office the office well
that gets they mix you missus okay and I
tested the medicine positively toward
the negative well apparently in the
medicine community negative means good
yeah that was amazing yeah I tested very
positive pause that was a big show that
she's never got into you I'd never given
myself the chance oh my what's wrong
so big and I never got it I go against
the grain I've never gotten into it she
in the sign field no I liked other shows
that were fun it like in the friends no
I thought Frazier was really funny
Fraser's awesome really funny I I
watched Seinfeld in France but I thought
Frasier was really fun that was my
favorite like sitcom of that time and
like I watched most things that people
watch her watch Ozark I think it's good
I don't think it's the greatest thing
ever but like ozoni like better surprise
I mean all of that the wires Sopranos
Breaking Bad I mean a succession is
better than those are game of Thrones I
mean it is Game of Thrones is watch
succession if those watching say you
have you ever watch that on HBO what's a
great it's about like a family of ultra
wealthy people that owned a TV station
it's great let's done school it's really
cool I started watching narcos Mexican
tacos the first season was amazing
second season make you starts bland
don't care starts you look about the
character it's like wait a minute we
don't know the real story the Hispanics
sell drugs yes that's a joke and a lot
of that is because we colonized and did
all the wrong things but yeah that's
just that's that's if you know the
history of it like the more I read the
actual history of it then I'm into it
more on the second season of Mexico's -
the third season they should do like
Norco in America do something to have
white people be the problem you know
what I mean whoa do narcos Alaska do
narcos health Hells Angels yeah some
like that you know no yes so the very I
don't know I'm trying to do real one you
know Zork is good it's a watchable show
the kid on Ozark is fans of a lot of
podcasts which is good you know the
clothes good the real whites now not the
yonk ad white trash the white trash kid
who's let's the old lady foxy lady
he's a
huge fan of all of the podcast well a
kid Charlie that kid that kid he does a
lot of work
he's like a massive fan of podcasting
hmm I don't want to get him in trouble
he looks like you're podcasting yeah I
mean he looks like a guy that like
podcast yeah he does I mean he's good
actor really good actor he plays the
same kind of part all the time which is
like what he looks like you apply yes
yeah he always our top five now it's
shocking one last time you watch the
premise it's amazing I know you have a
show that's here no slack out over scene
Sopranos I'll explain to you what tells
me to watch it
I wish it could never happen and it's
stupid it's from happy it could not have
mom Missouri I on a boat where a drug
dealers selling heroin on a boat cuz a
bunch of other people know a casino but
its sake you're like yeah whatever it's
like none of them could ever have it's
stupid
you're right and behavin and Laura
Linney are amazing Julia Garner's
amazing amazing that's where the show so
good because the actors sell it but
you're like dude this could never
[ __ ] happen you watch Game of Thrones
and think it could really happen
no but Game of Thrones is also not at
the level of like the wire the Sopranos
things like that
dude you and I are off I think Game of
Thrones better than all those like why
are all the seasons how many season six
why you're in totality is I ready show
how to create once you get into town one
two three no it's also good the other
ones alright in totality because it took
an issue and then showed it from every
different perspective it was like this
brilliant thing that had never been
really done in TV the way it had been
done were it's like you're looking at it
from the cops the dealer is the press
the politicians agree it's crazy it's to
do that with televisions wild rye
agreeing so that's why people put so
much weight on Sopranos because like
we've never seen like someone so
vulnerable no it's amazing that they
hear out Breaking Bad all that's like
now that we're in 2020 do you need a
season four Ozark let's be honest I'll
do I ever do you really I don't I don't
know where they gonna go yeah I mean you
said laundering money you get stood
stuffing money in their breasts he was a
gangster no but I heard that was good
here you bloody
bloodline is good on Netflix but it's
slow but it's good and it's got some
great actors in it shatters amazing the
night hunters on the Amazon no is that
good great do blood ladders could exist
in the Florida Keys
Oh anything Florida on the mouth besides
really yeah I'm starting to the Florida
movement what is wrong with you I like
alligators but other than that I'm just
out of look at that look at that there's
something afoot something's gonna better
curb is it I can't his grant curbs on me
what you can't believe I don't love
those are yes dude it's fine it's not
bad I respect it what about
documentaries I love documentaries
well did you were you a tiger King fan
great when your favorites I loved it
top five docs ever ah see I disagree
okay give me back I know it was so good
because we're in quarantine it was so
outlandish but if you could go back and
watch it is it better than like you know
why can't a murder it's better than the
OJ Simpson no no no you're wrong you're
right you're right is it bad and [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with cats along it got a
little long little cats to people I know
but it took too long that Facebook group
did I should happen in an episode I was
about to kill some of those losers
stalking this poor guy who gives a [ __ ]
yeah don't hurt cats but also who has a
job here ah dude how can I like the one
guy the guy who actually found them I
don't know what he does for a job he
goes I felt like you is a game of cat
and mouse and I got you know what you're
on yeah six years later Your Honor I've
got nothing to do this let's go then
show me that he's in LA they show me
that la [ __ ] coffee shop just [ __ ]
track in the dude it shows that
everybody just wants a community yes
everybody just wants a community whether
you're hunting a cat killer or whatever
it is you're just you're but I like
tiger king because is one of the only
things I didn't know like I don't not
one of the only things I don't know
about but like I don't know anything
about like those shitty zoos and I
always wondered about it when I would
drive through these areas I'd be like
yeah what is that a zoo
I'm like what the hell's going on there
like you go the Everglades in Florida
and you believe somebody what is this
thing but also kind of took you to that
world that interesting why yeah but
there's also this is what happens when a
guy who's addicted to meth gets a bunch
of tigers
it's like meth Tigers but he's the hero
of it like he's the hero that holds any
the heroes II think he's a hero you cut
her worse and what's her name Karen
what's her narrow Herald no no bad
Harold she had her husband killed and
she got away with it he this is a poor
guy who's like yeah C's in math had yes
he's tricked these guys into sleep he
also killed a lot of tigers ever but a
straight guy that that came from
Oklahoma was like didn't ever see Tigers
every podcast have all of these people
on by the way I don't think so we didn't
yeah but a lot of them dead and they all
kill Tigers I interviewed one of the
Tigers oh you did we did a video
woody Sanger he was an anti-semite so he
had to leave by this sense it's uh yeah
I think that podcasters goodbye think
it's also it's kind of like that the
Tiger Woods and Tom Brady golf thing
we're so hungry for live TV and for live
sports we're like alright I'll watch
this it's you know it's a came out in
2008 we just like very cool no it was
certainly a perfect storm of why it got
so big yeah 100%
cuz like stairs is better the going
clear docs better the Nirvana one of
Kurt Cobain HBO's better right now any
Tiger King was pretty good you have to
you have to care about Tigers well
you've been going clear it's like you
know that's a decent one who took
Johnnie's a creepy one about human
trafficking that's wild uh they can
murder make you murder is great
the keepers was good on Netflix keepers
is good but yeah Murder two was a waste
of your [ __ ] life yeah so lame
well it's also like he did it he do
indeed represent self as the lawyer yeah
we know he did it his attorney looks
guilty this [ __ ] they all drive her
these people live in a level from Donkey
Kong Country they just drive around in
minecarts and [ __ ] each other there dude
they're guilty enough and I said stop
trying to spring this guy who's clearly
a monster what's funny is I
when I came out I kind of defend him I
think we need to get him out and then
people from that County when I dude it's
all the Netflix marketing propaganda
this dude's so guilty things funny
students we don't feel like he's guilty
of like other things yes sick raped
people yeah he's a bad dude what else
you got
all right this is big right now Khloe
Kardashian and how she looks dude I mean
this is this is the chocolate face this
is where you get conspiracies where it's
like who did Chloe die and they just put
this new person in because this is the
craziest thing I've ever seen not do me
a favor bring up old Khloe Kardashian
picture tell me it's the same person
Giudice is how crypt that that that
doesn't do dust justice now get older
clothes do all the chlorine Chloe was a
[ __ ] starting left tackle for the
Colorado Buffaloes she was so big dude
look at that think how far science and
medicine has advanced but I gotta be
honest with you the new version of her
does not look like that doesn't look
like a human brow Brendan does that look
like a human being looks like a human
allowed to have sexual resolve but it
does it look at the eyes look very
closely at the eyes should be an alien
I'd still think okay it looks like
something's wrong like you'd like that's
crazy how so I mean it just doesn't she
did Kathy Griffin this is the same thing
she doesn't look alive anymore this is
not like old cattle your life anew Kathy
wasn't looking it's like that movie get
how it looks alive it's like that movie
get out something's wrong look at you
look dude she looks alive there she
might not want to [ __ ] her she looks a
lot fiber in there she looks alive
shoots alive and the other day or the
other that dutiful there's something's
off it looks like the movie get out Tom
took Chloe's brain and putting some huh
[ __ ] let's get out Wow dude shows you
what medicine can do yeah man I don't
know that that's you might have sold her
soul the devil but that's okay I guess
it's worth it alright he's so skinny now
let me see her full body they show it
here
I think the last thing she did was run
Jen and a black girl she went chocolate
body it's like the last thing she's not
tan there hmm
it's just her running do Rocky never ran
in a gated community
I mean it's god bless her but good for
her man good for her
I mean I'm glad she lost so that way but
I mean she's a pretty girl I don't know
why you need to go crazy with the face
she's pretty hot there look at all the
comments there's yes baby there she is
yeah I mean she does look pretty damn
amazing right here doesn't know like you
said it didn't look real it just doesn't
look real my boy Kardashians
it doesn't look like a human being I
mean even the tits look weird like yes
right her looks and she's also can we
she also has the skin of sexy Yama
she's also gold this that's not natural
color now she's also a gold bronze shape
no that's plenty
what's that makeup on the body really
yeah
a lot of girls do that now where they
have like body shimmer that's what it
was like gold and bronze on dude wears
when is this gonna be done - Rob
Kardashian I mean when is Rob Rob knife
all of the night sued Rob's 400 pounds
yeah he tried come up with the sock
business no one supported it poor rot me
robber outside Denny's in Huntington
Beach with guns saying open now I know
what supports rod man they're like geez
what's wrong with Rob he's the black
sheep of family well I don't know maybe
does he even have an Instagram I have
taken a photo of that guy in like years
I think that's so fat-shamed
then also like they were sitting around
the mom was or straight or constraining
the businesses she goes hi Rob so socks
for you yeah you'll get size
this poor guy Lemmy mamasita limited
dish I did how how meanwhile this is a
horrific situation fimo sisters are
signed with [ __ ] adidas they're
billionaires dude dude I love they go
through all the houses at they all own
and then they're like Rob sleeps on one
of their couches you know what I was
still sad about [ __ ] Lamar oh I'm
just eating Papa John's in someone's
backyard there's no photos I know that's
an old one
there's an old one man he's had a tough
go man he's got a tough go what happened
to him I think his sister got famous for
[ __ ] a dude I mean really man man in
that world Bruce Jenner date Lamar Odom
the only well I knew us as the most Pro
all have issues and you're around that
and your father was a successful lawyer
yeah you're making socks yeah you got to
be very careful around these ladies one
bad break away from making don't [ __ ]
with cats - who's got Disick somehow
made it because he's like a Long Island
it's got this like slimeball he figured
that she has a good brand called you
talentless yeah it's a clothing brand
called talentless it's actually a really
good gear I love it yeah I mean I always
liked him me too yeah he's good that is
because we're scum yeah that's fair yeah
I've always [ __ ] with uh I've always
[ __ ] with him yeah we're scum I mean
you know I get him I what's he supposed
to do like I get it he just he gave me I
married into an attractive a like a
wealthy family bull the spirits died
that stuff that is tough yeah I respect
a lot of nothing
I mean Hustle is a hustle or from out of
hustle man yeah he's a hustle he's
making the best that I respect that man
yeah a long island god I cannot I cannot
support Long Island
happy birthday the best guy I know Rob
Kardashian well won't you [ __ ] help
him out where is he where is he he's
busy right now Rob no thought what about
Rob what if he's just getting like super
jacked right now during quarantine and
he's waiting to just calm his sisters
have all the connections these sisters
Kanye got light bulbs for sweaters you
put them under the night
food get some [ __ ] chicken playing
put them onto that night we'll see that
I bet soon I mean how great would it be
if the next photo is Rob Kardashian it
looks like Khloe toe like this is Rob
Kardashian it's a picture of a guy
that's not even click on that picture
the top left the very first picture what
is that it's the old app time fly ash
stay home Oh God
gotcha yeah all right what else you got
yeah the dish one here this is from
Sports Center it's actually pretty
entertaining
[Music]
it's the same with tiger King yeah yeah
just me like Netflix meets content yeah
all right you succumb to that I succumb
to it you like check this [ __ ] out this
is a 8 year old and I don't know you
guys tell me if this looks real to you
or not but this is seems like these days
[Music]
I believe that yeah why not
that's just seems impossible what else
is he gonna do I don't know who was it
Khloe Kardashian is that what Khloe
looks like that Roger - you know is that
there now it's like we can't even be
shocked if Rob Kardashian just small
Asian oh yeah small blip on my radar if
that was Rob Kardashian thrice Pozzo by
Soleri yeah that's crazy good for him
I'll buy socks what else you got stuff
sold the real Khloe Kardashian for
experiments and then they put in this
new one Lotus yeah that's all we got
that's it that's it we did it dude
that's it thanks for having me dude
thanks very much hold on it Tim Dylan
show on YouTube please subscribe fight
the power fight tech censorship and by
subscribing to my channel and buying my
merch that is the most important way to
fight this really yes I mean that
just what it is dude I can't think you
know you got to do the shows with us in
yeah no I'm gonna do it I feel legit sit
down I'll do it no I'm down okay awesome
yeah
thank you everyone with June 11th
through 13th yeah Phoenix June 11
through 13 are you getting to fly him
you're a gangster
alright alright come on you want to
drive I might drive oh we have ours oh
he knows in 48 hours your car's gonna
melt
no oh as it gets real hot so I think
it'd be nice be nice desert drive though
I like driving myself I like charge 90
desert of drive time from Los Angeles to
Phoenix yes yeah I think eubie eubie
you'd be surprised yeah
no pun intended my special guest you
know that's not taking you five minutes
you might make it before you go over
forty-five going for forty-five there
well that's 107 miles yes to the speed
limit you're getting there in under 500
I'm not mad at that
no I like that instead of going on plane
getting old gross stop lunch have some
watching the desert two-and-a-half you
stop lunch the desert another two and a
half you there
I leave early there's literally 200
miles to get to the mountains up you
something Palm Springs yeah dude I mean
I think that better than getting on a
fly
that's smart even though I do want to
get on a flight to just kind of get back
in the swing of things I'm gonna do in
Houston but I might drive there I think
Ryan have my brother fly to LA and then
we drive from LA to Phoenix yeah I think
I think Jay drivings to move dude I
think you're right yeah that's gonna be
a great show yeah Tim Dean Ellis join us
in Phoenix yeah 11th to the 13th Bryan
Tim and me and Phoenix stand-up live
then spokane is june 25th to 27th 27th
the first-ever ignarro thick boys bike
club meeting if you want in on that we
got over 200 riders on how we're gonna
do it but thick boy ride at gmail.com
and then in Salt Lake City
wise guys stand up July 16th through the
18th also the 18th is when we're doing
the thick boys ride also email thick boy
ride at gmail.com to sign up for the
ride in Utah Tim thanks for coming in
thank you brother like this is the
fighter in the Tim we're out